welcome back to Facebook now since it's
a big budget Netflix series on Cleopatra
it's been hit with claims of cultural
vandalism over the casting of black
actress Adele James and the lead role
Cleopatra's precise Heritage is a point
of scholarly debate there's no evidence
that she was black and the casting has
caused major controversy in Egypt
spurring a lawsuit Ang claims the
program makers are erasing Egyptian
identity it's not the first casting
controversy we've seen of course the
backlash is normally the other way
around Brian Cranston was lambastian for
playing a disabled character in The
Upside as was Jake Gyllenhaal who
starred in The Prince of Persia despite
not being Persian or a prince and of
course Eddie Redmayne who is the
groveling apology for playing a trans
woman in the Danish girl so he's casting
Cleopatra as a black woman culturally
insensitive should we care isn't the job
of an actor after all to act well
joining me now is legendary Egyptian
comedian Bassin Yousef and author of The
Case of the canceled culture
Ernest Owens well welcome to both of you
okay let me start with you
Ernest Darlings off you go
yeah um I think that this is ridiculous
I think that she
um is in full range to play Cleopatra I
think people should remember that there
was controversy when the late great
Elizabeth Taylor played Cleopatra and
people thought that it was inaccurate
for a white woman like her to play the
character
um history has said that there is some
racial ambiguity around
um Cleopatra's identity she's definitely
not white and I think to even assume
that Egyptians do not carry some level
of African ancestry that can have a
darker skin complexion is also
historically inaccurate so I think she's
more of
the idea of what Cleopatra will look
like more than Elizabeth Taylor would be
and you didn't see as much backlash for
Elizabeth Taylor playing
that's the fair point so let me go to
you best I mean that is a fair point Liz
Liz Taylor was the biggest movie star in
the world at the time she played
Cleopatra she was not Egyptian what's
the difference
well first of all this was Hollywood
before it was informed this is where
1961 when Cleopatra by the Elizabeth
said we're not crazy about Elizabeth
Taylor playing Cleopatra either that was
also inaccurate I don't know where do
you get the idea that we're happy that
she played the role as a matter of fact
1961 Cleopatra movie was banned in 19 in
Egypt and many Arab countries because of
Elizabeth Taylor's stands towards the
the state of Israel because they will
supported them so I don't know where
does he kind of get this information
second of all this is the same Hollywood
that in 1956 they cast John Wayne at
junkie's hand so this is a time where
Hollywood didn't know any better now the
problem for me it's not about color it's
not about white and black this is a very
reductive way to talk about things this
is the way that Americans talk about it
I'm very sorry like I come from Egypt
Egypt has a very diverse color palette
people can look like me or they can look
deeper skin tone like Anor said who
comes from a Nubian origin it's not
about black and white it's about the
continuous culture appropriation and
falsification of history that has been
done by what the so-called afrocentris
movement the Afrocentric movement
started the last century as a way in a
good intention to teach African-American
about their Rich history of West Africa
the great Empire of Benin of Ghana over
sungali the great Empire of Mali but the
thing is that's why you find people like
Kevin Hart Who subscribes to these
theories who claim that his ancestors
play uh build the pyramids I'm sorry
your ancestors had their own wonderful
civilization in West Africa they are
culture appropriating my culture calling
the people of Egypt of today despite
their skin tone that they call us as
Invaders
as Intruders and and they are being
erased by from our own history this is
something that Hollywood has done over
the years back here at this point that
we've had so many cases now where people
talk about appropriation with actors be
it their sexuality be it their gender on
occasion be whatever it may be and
ultimately I always come back to one
point which is shouldn't actors do what
their job description is act I mean it
shouldn't any actor be able to play any
part actually and once you start making
exceptions for that rule where do you
stop
is that question for me yeah
yeah well first of all this is not a
work of fiction this is a documentary
this is a documentary this is a huge
difference this is not the little
mermaid which is like a fictional
character where you can anybody can play
anything the uh Cleopatra which came
from a Macedonian Greek origin and the
thing is it's not about like the skin
color as I don't we don't care about if
they're black or white it's about it's
about how Hollywood is so culturally
sensitive and they're so sensitive about
all kind of of minorities but when it
comes to my people we seem to be erased
a couple of years ago they announced
that galgado and ex Israeli soldier who
condones her government actions
atrocities against Palestinian children
she was going to play Cleopatra for me
this is even a bigger insult and galgado
is not black it's not about black and
white it's about this idea of of
Hollywood always stealing by the culture
of my own people I don't care what
Charlton Heston tells you in the Ten
Commandments or Steven Spielberg tells
you in The Prince of Egypt but I am
sorry Jewish slaves did not build the
Great Pyramid this has been debunked
many times by historians
we are we are the only people who are
not allowed to to to to talk about our
own history
okay hang on hang on Ernest let me ask
you a question on this which is how
would you feel if a white actor was
chosen to play Nelson Mandela
I think that there is historical
inaccuracies there I think that you know
I think what he's confusing is race and
nationality and I also think that that
is why you don't see as many black
actors upset at Cynthia rivo who is
British who played you know Harriet
because we understand the nuances of
racial identity compared to nationality
versus
um the identity of the African diaspora
so no one's upset about the fact that
David on Yahoo played m-ok
um there may be some people but others
didn't because we understood the Nuance
of racial identity so when we're talking
about race and nationality those are two
different things but I think the issue
that that I didn't want to push back on
what he said earlier is that there are
other actors in This film that are
playing Egyptians that do not look like
Cleopatra or come from there and I just
feel like the energy being focused on
Cleopatra is why some people are pushing
back because this actress could easily
look by identity looks closer to what it
Cleopatra it could look like but the
rest of that cast is fairly white and
you're not saying anything about those
individuals you're only focused on
Cleopatra who's being played by this
black actress but when we look at the
other casts I don't think they're all
Egyptian I don't think they all
represent the cast
okay let me bring back by step I mean if
this was in a theater production I could
imagine this happening without people
creating much of a fuss is it because
it's a Hollywood movie and Hollywood's
put itself in the Vanguard it's a
culture
it's a documentary Hollywood has been
erasing my people from like 10 we have
are not allowed to tell our own history
and I'm sorry I have to disagree with
the gentleman it's not about it's every
it's not just Cleopatra everybody in
that movie Her Court everybody who's
supposed to be Egyptian they looked like
they came from West African the south of
the Sahara we as Egyptians are being
called Intruders and Invaders in our own
culture this has been going on
systematically I don't want to wake up
one day and find in the Museum of the
African-American culture and history
claiming the stolen Egyptian artifacts
in the in the British museum to be
theirs and now I'm hearing that Zendaya
the very popular actor who I would love
her to play any but Zendaya ethnically
is is half Nigerian half German and now
she's gonna play where are those where
are the Egyptian actors where are the
where are the Arab actors who supposed
it and the thing is the even like
historically wise you see in the in in
the in the trailer it's like I don't
care what what you're what they told you
but Cleopatra was black Who's That Woman
why is African-American people are
telling my own history she is there
there's all of these pseudoscience and
pseudo history has been going on and it
has implications no I am sorry African
people from West Africa could not build
the pyramids okay Cleopatra did not like
like that and if also Jewish people do
not build the pyramids okay it is time
for Hollywood to listen to the people
who own that history why
Egypt Egypt Egypt had 30 Dynasty over 2
700 years we had kings and queens from
the kingdom of kush the from Nubia from
Libya this area had all had bled into
each other and expanded and shrunk into
each other I understand exactly what I
mean when I say nationality okay or
Heritage or ethnicity you both made your
points yeah it's an interesting debate
thank you both very much indeed